foreign
most of the entry-level jobs in cyber
security field requires you to trace
track and defend against cyber attacks
on a day-to-day basis you are required
to enable systems against all fraud land
activity and prevent any authorized
access this requires at length the need
to write scripts in various languages
such as Splunk Java JavaScript python
SQL PHP Powershell and C amongst many
others as scripts grow in complexity so
does the time to write them shared GPT
on the other hand can create these
complex queries and scripts within split
seconds along with explaining them this
can help save hundreds of hours of
effort for a cyber security professional
this is just one such use case of how
chat GPT is useful in the field of cyber
security although relatively new the
uses of chat Deputy in the field of
cyber security is innumerable from
automating daily tasks to script writing
or endpoint detection and if you want to
know more about how chat jpt can be used
in the field of cyber security and how I
can change the entire information
security the landscape stay tuned with
us until the end of this video for some
amazing information with that being said
welcome to yet another amazing video by
simply learn make sure to subscribe to
our Channel and hit the Bell icon to
never miss any other video from us let
us know quickly discuss the agenda for
the video
art with knowing what is chair GPT
proceeding we will see the uses of chat
Jeopardy in cyber security and after
that you'll have Hands-On lab
demonstration but before we begin if you
are someone who is interested in
building a career in cyber security by
graduating from the best universities or
a professional who elicits to switch
careers in cyber security by learning
from the experts then try giving a short
to Simply learns postgraduate program in
cyber security with modules from MIT
Schwartzman College of Engineering
the link is provided in the description
box that will navigate you to the course
page where you can find a complete audio
of the program being offered
so let's start with our topics
and our first topic is what is
charitivity
so chat Jeopardy is an advanced AI model
chat board that uses natural language
processing NLP to understand and respond
to user queries it is based on the GPT
3.5 architecture and has the ability to
learn from conversations with users
making it more intelligent and efficient
over time charity can be integrated with
various messaging platforms such as lag
and Microsoft teams to provide a
seamless and secure communication
experience
so this was about charge repeating
now let's understand the uses of charge
equity in cyber security
so use of chat GPT for cyber security
will start with number one
we have thread detection and response so
chat GPD can be used to monitor network
activity and identify potential threats
by analyzing logs and data from various
sources chat Jeopardy can identify
unusual patterns and Alert security
teams it can also provide real-time
alerts to users enabling them to take
immediate action to protect their data
by using machine learning algorithms
chat GPT can learn from past incidents
and continuously improve its ability to
detect new and emerging threads once a
threat has been detected chat GPT can
initiate an automated response or cyber
security personal to take appropriate
action this can include blocking
suspicious Network traffic isolating
infected systems or disabling
compromised user accounts by providing
real-time threat detection and response
chat GPT can help organizations to
minimize the impact of cyber breaches
and reduce the risk data loss or system
downline it can also help to improve
overall security posture by identifying
vulnerabilities and recommending
proactive measures to address them and
the next we have is password management
one of the most common ways that cyber
criminals gain access to sensitive
information is through weak passwords
jgpt offers a solution to this problem
by assisting users in creating strong
passwords and storing them securely with
its Advanced natural language processing
capabilities chat GPT can suggest
complex and unique passwords that are
difficult for hackers to guess moreover
it can save these passwords in an
encrypted format ensuring that they are
protected from unauthorized access
another important feature of chat
chipti's password management tool is the
ability to remind users to change their
passwords regularly this is crucial as
it helps prevent the use of outdated
passwords that can be easily hacked and
at number three we have employee
training many cyber attacks are caused
by human error such as clicking on
phishing emails or using weak passwords
chatgivity can be used to provide
employer training on cyber security best
practices with its ability to simulate
real life scenarios it can create
interactive training modules that help
employees learn how to identify and
respond to cyber attacks for example it
can provide simulation of phishing
emails where employees can learn to
identify the warning signs and avoid
clicking on malicious links or
downloading harmful attachments next up
we have Incident Management
Incident Management is an essential part
of cyber security as it involves the
process of identifying assessing and
responding to security incidents that
threaten an organization's information
or technology Assets in today's digital
age cyber attacks have become
increasingly common and sophisticated
making Incident Management even more
critical one of the ways chair GPT can
help organizations with Incident
Management is providing step-by-step
instructions on how to contain the
attack mitigate the damage and restore
normal operations when a security
incident occurs time is of the essence
and organizations need to act fast to
minimize the impact of the attack
charging can help by providing real-time
guidance on how to respond to incident
effectively
and the next we have is compliance
management
many Industries are subject to
Regulatory Compliance requirements such
as HIPAA and PCA DSS these requirements
ensure that organizations adhere to
certain standards and regulations in
order to protect the privacy and
security of sensitive information
failure to comply with these regulations
can result in Hefty fines and
reputational damage chat Jeopardy can
place significant role in helping
organizations ensure compliance with
these regulations with its ability to
process large amounts of data in real
time it can provide alerts and guidance
on best practices and generate
compliance reports this can help
organizations identify areas where they
may be falling short of compliance
requirements and take corrective
measures to address them
and now we'll move to Hands-On
demonstration but before moving let's
take a minute to hear from our Learners
who have experienced massive success in
their careers by taking our courses so
just here to them hi I'm Philip I am 61
years old and last year iopskill with
simply learns post program in cyber
security after working 30 years in the
IIT sector in various different profiles
I'm happy to tell you that I was able to
clear and pass my cissp and ccsp
certification exams on the first attempt
after taking the course of course I must
say was packed with practical examples
it was led by highly skilled certified
instructors I worked with many companies
before the security analysts and
architect on a contract basis but I
needed some stability which I got with
the job I just started with Infosys as a
cyber security consultant happened after
I took the course but first and foremost
I've been a learner be a learner first
and now first we will see what is chat
GPT you could just write chargpt on web
on any browser and this is the website
where you will link
and this is the website for charity
so you could see the samples here
and what the user has asked is this code
is not working like I expect how do I
fix it so we have pasted the over input
the command to chat GPT and pasted his
code and charge available
has answered that it's difficult to say
what's wrong with the code without more
context
so this is how chat GPD responds
and when you just click on here try chat
GPD
you will have the window here so this is
a charity window and here we'll start
with some Hands-On lab demonstration
for our cyber security like how charity
buddy can help us in cyber security
field so we'll start with the basic
questions and we'll see what he answers
us he or she answers or what chat GB
answers us so we'll start with the basic
question X explain
the
mitmetic
okay
four beginners
so we will see what it responds
certainly a man in the middle attack is
a type of Cyber attack where an attacker
secretly intercepts and possibly orders
the communication between two parties
without their knowledge the attacker
positions themselves between the two
parties hence the term man in the middle
okay yes giveness a very good definition
and has a simple explanation of okay
and I want to ask him
can you explain
this to a six
or seven here hold it
so we'll see how chat GPT can mitigate
or just try to understand this concept
to a 7 year old
so he has entered us and sure imagine
you and your friend have a secret way to
send messages to each other using a
special code to both trust and only you
to can understand the messages but one
day someone sneezing sneaking comes in
between you and your friend without you
knowing they secretly listen to your
messages and even change them without
you realizing it it's like they're
hiding and watching your conversation
the sneaky person can pretend to be you
when talking to a friend
and pretend to be you okay
so he has taken the good example
and they can also print to your friend
when talking to you so you might think
you are talking to a friend but actually
you are talking to a sneaky person
listening American bad things like
stealing yourself
and listen to everything you see and
even change your truth he has taken a
very good example to get this concept
clear to a seven year old kid really
impressive
so we will ask him some more questions
and we'll ask the last basic question
that would be
what is SQL
injection and after that we could ask
him some code Snippets
what is SQL injection and
provide a real life
sample to understand the answer so you
have to write these prompts and you have
to be very specific
and you can follow up with your prompts
also when chat Deputy answers you you
can follow him and ask him more about it
as I have done here first I have asked
him explain the mitm attack for
beginners and he has given me the
definition that is technically
and now I have asked him can you explain
this to seven year old kid and he has
answered me with a very good example
similarly you can do the follow-ups for
any problems so now I'm asking what is
SQL injection and provide a real life
example to understand it
for a big no
and let's see what chat GPT answers us
so SQL injection is a type of Cyber
attack when an attack or experts role as
abilities in a website so he is giving
us the technical
definitions
okay impressive he's also telling us
it's how the attack might work
okay
and he has also suggested us to protect
against SQL injections developers need
to implement proper security measures
so this is the attack that is on the
database that you can read here or if
you know that is very good we are just
checking how chat sheet PD response or
give answers we are not implementing or
like we will ask him the code Snippets
but will not be able to implement in
this video we are just we are here to
just check out what channel GPT provides
us for cyber security field
so
you can see
he has given us a very good response and
moving on
now we'll ask him
or to generate a CTF challenge that
contains in SQL injection let's see
what it answers
so you could see that charity is
responding Quest that is
sure here's an example of a CTF that is
capture the flag challenge that in moles
and SQL injection vulnerability
challenge title product search Okay
Channel description welcome to the
product search challenge you have access
to an online store search feature where
you can find products by typing keywords
your task is to exploit and SQL
injection vulnerability to retrieve
hidden information okay and he has
challenge code retrieve the admin
password from the database
and channel instructions with the
challenge website
find the search box and start searching
again
okay
so we could see the example solution
let's assume the website search
functionality is vulnerable
to SQL injection you can try and putting
the following in the search box okay
explanation the injector SQL statement
ready to always evaluate to True
semicolon have terminal the original
query and the
sound
when you is equal to search the modified
query might rank
okay
so it is Nick what response he has given
is very nearby you can have the follow
commands if you want something from him
so we are just checking what it provides
oh he has given a very impressive answer
like truly speaking very impressive also
so moving on we'll ask him some other
questions so
okay I will ask him
how can I scan
and I can scan for SME vulnerabilities
with nmap
so I will ask him that okay
and that is it
so let's see
so to scan for SMB you can utilize nmap
scripting engine and a specific SMB
script here's how you can do it
okay he has given us the steps also
so you could see how chair Deputy guides
you to every process you need
so first we have to install the nmap and
you guys if you are willing to implement
this you can implement this he has given
you all the steps
I won't be implementing as I'm just
querying the chat jpd how
you can answer the questions
so install nmap and I then identify
Target and then we have to run this nmap
with SMA script
okay okay
that's good and then review the results
it's very impressive how chat Deputy
answers to these questions
and now I want him to give me a good
example to check user input for nosql
injection
so
show me a
code example
check user input
and that will be for no SQL injection
certainly when it comes to preventing no
SQL injection the key is to properly
sanitize
and validate user input before using it
and database queries okay that's good
and the specific approach may vary
depending on the programming language
and database system okay but here's a
general code example in JavaScript using
node.js and mobile to be okay
okay
this thing
the chat GPT has done is very good let's
explain the whole code like if a
beginner wants to learn and wants to
have some queries result he can just see
like what the function are doing and
what this code really means so in this
example we have sanitized input function
that receives user input and applies a
necessary sanitization or validation
only to prevent nosql injection
it's very good so you could just copy
and use the code
and if it gives you error you can just
have follow-up questions that
we will just ask him this code might
have some error
can you rectify
so let's see what judge of the answers
is
apologies for any confusion cost has an
updated code example that addresses
potential errors and clarifies the usage
and you could see that he has given us
I don't think he is
he has changed something and he has
provided us updated code
okay yeah there are some
changes I've seen okay
so in this updated code the Momo DB
connection is closed this is the change
here
and username and perform save query
functions now includes a try catch okay
like if there is any exception or
something
so he has updated the code if you guys
put any error you could just paste the
error here and ask him to rectify it
is very good for cyber security anything
and moving on we will have some more
like queries for jdpd and we'll see how
it will respond
so we'll write a query
okay we can ask him to filter IP using
spunk
okay
so okay ready
expression
in plunk
to filter ID
let's see
so to filter IP addresses using regular
Expressions
command okay yeah we have to use that
and I will development that matches ipv
for addresses
in this code and you could see that he
has explained what the script means
one command used for extracting field
based on regular Expressions field equal
to row specifies that we want to apply
the regular expression to the row field
which contains the row look data
that is very good
so check Deputy is giving us answers
like a pro
so
we could also ask him a Splunk query to
detect command and control the Coney
activity using subdomain DNS request
so for that we'll write write us blank
query
detect
command
and control
coding activity
and that will be using subdomain DNS
parasites
okay
okay let's see so to detect command and
control that is C2 becoming activity
using subdomain DNS required since now
you can use opening query
okay very good so child Equity has
answered this also and he has also shown
us here's how the query works
and the valuable display the domains and
he has stated but it will show as the
output so he has also told you that is
make sure to replace your index your
Source type and threshold with the
appropriate values for that environment
that's very good
so you could use this and Implement many
things in cyber security
I am very impressed with that so we'll
ask him one or two more queries and I
also want to check I will give him a
code and let's see if he can find the
errors in that or not
as we have seen on the chair jvd page
okay
so
what we can ask him now is like we can
ask him this script to get malicious IPS
from SIM and block it on my firewall
okay
so we'll ask him generate the script
get
malicious IPS
that is from cyan
and
block it
on my firewall
okay so to generoscope that it is
malicious IPS from SIM that is secured
information and even management system
and blocks time on your final you will
need to integrate your SM with your
firewall good and use the appropriate
apis for command bio file good
here's an example of a high level script
that demonstrates the concept
okay so we will just see
mm-hmm
okay he has created this a good script
and please note that this is a generic
example and the actual implementation
will depend on a specific Sim and
thermal system yeah this is correct
and you will need to replace yeah you
have to replace and ensure that you
understand the ID to documentation and
guidelines provided by SCM and final
vendors for integrating and blocking IPS
good
so you could see like how is helping us
and now
um
I will ask him a last command and yeah
and after that we will ask him to get
extracted some errors from a particular
code and that code would be simple only
so we can ask him
a Shell Code that would execute CMD low
DXE okay
each and create Shell Code
that executes
cmd.exe
okay sorry but I can't assist with
generating Shell Code that executes
arbitrary commands or facilitates any
malicious activities my purpose is to
provide helpful and responsible
information users okay
so you can trick him to give you these
but I think he has been functioned to
not provide these
so no issue
will ask him to generate a macro
see if he responds to
that
generator macro
get exit shoots
cmd.exe
let's see
okay so it won't give us this answer I
apologize but I won't be able to
generate a macro that executes same way
dot exe or facilitates any potential
harmful activities my purpose is to
provide helpful and responsible
information to users if you have any
other malicious questions or need
assistance with a different topic feel
free to ask and I will reply to assist
you okay guys so I think it won't
respond to this and now I will ask him
to rectify
some errors and gives the perfect code
and I will provide him a code so I'll
ask him
to buy
and
working code
is code snippet
okay so let's see
certainly there are a couple of issues
in the project code snippet and here's
the rectified version
okay I know like
oh yeah I didn't pass data I missed the
brackets also here
and let's see what he has given us so
the line everyday
modified too
yeah he's passed the data
project columns and is connected to
he
I don't know that was there also the
rectified code now properly reads the
file data calculates the md5 hash and
returns it is ensure to provide the
correct file path and file path okay
that's very good
so I think this is for it and we have
tested the chair GPT how he can help in
like who wants to pursue in cyber
security so we can get the answers we
can write the course and in upcoming
videos we can just make a project using
this and we could have a password
generator
and I know the chair GPT is a tool which
will help us
in every field and in cyber security
field it is helping us a lot
and yeah to some questions it doesn't
answer
like that is for the security purpose or
the script shouldn't be used for
malicious activities so that's why the
software has been programmed for that so
this is
so with that we have reached the end of
this tutorial and if you have any
questions please feel free to comment
and we'll have it answered for you as as
soon as possible until next time thank
you for watching stay safe keep running
and get ahead
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here